[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video arbeite ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut heute mit
einem wirklich sehr interessanten video
auf das ich mich sehr freue und sehr
gespannt wenn man sich meine haare an
schaut also die sind auf jeden fall
schon wieder ziemlich lang geworden um
ehrlich zu sein
deswegen gehen wir heute zum friseur
aber ihr kennt mich natürlich zu
irgendeinem friseur sondern wir gehen
zum schlechtesten friseur den es hier
gibt der stadt köln
ja richtig guter einwand von der seite
also leute vielleicht könnt ihr euch
noch daran erinnern ich habe das schon
mal gemacht das ist glaube ich ein stern
oder 15 mal 5 sterne friseur aus köln so
irgendwie und dort wurden meine haare
geschnitten
das problem war nur dieser laden hatte
auf seiner internetseite ich glaube gelb
wenn sich das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
diese extrem schlechte bewertung von 1 5
sternen das ding ist aber ich meine die
meisten leute bewerten hat einfach auf
google und dort sind dann auch die
meisten bewertungen und dort hatte
dieser friseurladen halt eine ziemlich
gute bewertung dh das war total
widersprüchlich und ersin zufall dass er
dort so schlecht bewertet war ich dann
auch in den kommentaren und ich war da
ja auch an sich mit meiner frisur
zufrieden auch wenn viele in den
kommentaren geschrieben hat alex das
sind wirklich nicht gut aus leute
deswegen heute mit einem neuen friseur
neues glück und da bin ich wirklich mal
gespannt der hat jetzt innerhalb von 2-3
monaten 5 1 sterne bewertung kassiert
die schauen wir uns mal an insgesamt ist
das ding mit zwei sternen bewertet und
ja da geht es gleich hin ich hoffe man
braucht keinen termin ja leute das ist
der wundervolle laden wir haben hier
also den namen finde ich allein schon so
irgendwie sehr seriös klingt das nicht
aber wo sich immer wieder sagen ich
möchte hier kein was böse ist deswegen
sehe ich dass bei diesen schlechten
videos ja es lustig ist ich wollte auch
schon anrufen man findet keine
telefonnummer im internet man findet
nicht mal eine internetseite das heißt
wenn ich die website clique kommt
einfach das also diese seite gibt es gar
nicht mehr
deswegen schauen wir uns jetzt erstmal
die letzten vier bewertungen an tobias
münch schreibt achtung lockvogelangebot
ausgeschildert mit 17 euro für
waschen schneiden und dann bekommt man
einen pfleger auf geschützte waschen
schneiden pflege für 24 euro
aber die pflege ist nur eine haarkur die
nach dem waschen zeit haben wir über
abzocker ungerechtfertig sieben euro den
ich war nicht auf krasse leider bin ich
zu diesem friseur gegangen es ist die
spitzen schreien und die dame hat mir
einfach 20 cm meine haare abgeschnitten
ich hatte sehr lange und gesunde haare
jetzt sind sie sehr kurz und das färben
hat meine haare zerstört naja juli
irgendwie bisher auch selber schuld
vielleicht sollte man fürs haare färben
dann schon eher den friseur auswählen wo
man weiß dass die qualität auch wirklich
gut ist eine komplett enttäuscht
mitarbeiter total das interessiert
bleibe also das ist alles wirklich nicht
gut jetzt hier was ihr steht deswegen
würde ich sagen wie lange man gar nicht
lange her dass man habe zeige ich euch
ja auch noch mal von der seite und von
hinten und wir fahren da einfach mal hin
ganz wichtig vielleicht vorweg für die
leute die vom dorf kommen so wie ich
eigentlich auch oder kleinstadt sagen
wir es mal so wenn ich bei mir zu hause
die haare schneidet kostet es 15 bis 17
euro
in köln ist das immer ein bisschen
teurer ich habe hier in köln auch schon
mal 30 bezahlt für einfach nur schneiden
bei jungs oder männern fand ich schon
viel deswegen wenn ich mal gespannt wie
teuer es hier wird und mexiko so leute
also ich bin fast da mal wieder in der
stadt also ziemlich stadtnahe ziemlich
zentral das ganze also ich denke mein
laden der sich darauf spezialisiert hat
einfach kunden rein raus ohne termin
haare stein raus rein
so kennt man ja noch keiner genau und
antesten laden ich bin gespannt und ich
hoffe die kriegen irgendwas vernünftiges
hin und meinen haaren ich bin erst als
sich der anspruchsvolle kunde und 20
glaubt so schwierig ist halt auch nicht
einmal bis in die seiten zu kürzen
bisschen kürzer ja also bis gleich jetzt
müsst ihr euch im regel auf
ich denke mir mal so ja ein stück kann
es ja auch laufen
jetzt muss ich einfach eineinhalb
kilometer laufen sondern sofort da
hallo
die vorne
ruhig schon einmal einen seite also auf
8 millimeter oben einfach ein bisschen
kürzer so müller raus das war schon eine
cola wasser
[Musik]
ja ganz entwachsen
noch sucht
[Musik]
heute das war es auch schon
also ich muss sagen ich war noch nie ich
muss ich gleich mal zählen alte leute
das ding ist ja nämlich ich will mir
immer durchgehend das ganze und das
video geht jetzt erst 15 minuten ich
habe schon so ungefähr zwei minuten vor
also die hatten maximal acht minuten die
haare geschnitten
ich weiß nicht ob wir das sehen könnt
aber ich glaube mein nacken ist übelst
roth junge die hatten mit ihrem kam also
ich erzähle euch gleich nochmal
ausführlich die hat mit ihrem kam da
drüber das hatte ich noch nie also
absolut keinen bock aber ich finde ich
sie eigentlich ganz gut aus oder also
was hat sie eigentlich ganz gut
hinbekommen um ehrlich zu sein
nur wie die das gemacht hat da bin ich
echt drauf klargekommen
so leute da bin ich wieder im auto
ja so sind meine haut weiter aus ich
will mal sagen wir machen mal schnell
einen vorher-nachher-vergleich den ich
euch jetzt mal kurz zeige dann könnt ihr
eure meinung dazu in die kommentare
schreiben
als co
[Musik]
die
ansonsten also ich muss wirklich sagen
dass war der schnellste friseurbesuch
meines lebens ich hab das ja wie gesagt
durch ge mit dem handy aufgenommen ich
habe gerade meinen kopf ich war etwas
über acht minuten im laden lecker nicht
also die kann maximal siebeneinhalb
minuten eher weniger meine haare
geschnitten haben also ich finde sie hat
ist relativ akkurat gemacht um ehrlich
zu sein jetzt keinen fehler aufgefallen
noch nicht nur die hat das in einem
tempo gemacht das habe ich noch nie
gesehen und vor allem auch so 0 mit ok
ich hab eigentlich bock leuchten die
haare zu schneiden
ich habe euch das ja eben schon gezeigt
ich weiß nicht ob es immer noch rot ist
hier hin natürlich kann es mal vorkommen
dass namen friseurbesuch irgendwie es
wurde stellen gibt weil da ja dieser
rasierer drüber gegangen ist aber so
extrem hab ich das wirklich noch nie als
das hat wirklich wo sie mit dem kam halt
über meine kopfhaut
das ganze hat mich sogar nur 15 euro
kostet mit waschen habt ihr am anfang
hört also sie hat auch einfach meine
haare gewaschen ich dachte so okay das
ist jetzt wahrscheinlich schon mal
sieben euro weil normalerweise ist das
so stand die auch in den bewertungen und
kommen dann auch auf den friseursalon an
vorne hin zum schild stand drauf waschen
schneiden und wachs für 18 euro deswegen
dachte ich halte das ich dann 18 euro
bezahle ich muss nur 15 euro bezahlen
ich weiß nicht warum das so war aber hat
mich auf jeden fall gefreut also ganz
normal der preis absolut in ordnung das
ergebnis finde ich eigentlich auch in
ordnung das einzige was halt absolut
schlecht ist war der service weil die
sehr unfreundlich war um ehrlich zu sein
also sie kamen mir wirklich unfreundlich
rüber und das überhaupt keinen bock
darauf hat der laden war ja auch
komplett leer bis auf mich ja noch so
ein typ
während die vielleicht ein bisschen
freundlicher könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass der laden gut wäre weil der hat
auch eine echt gute lage naja das kann
man nie so wirklich verstehen wir fahren
jetzt nach hause und jetzt muss ich erst
mal das essen
bis dann
[Musik]